aaron mckie can't get enough of far cry
3 blood dragon then look no further
presenting the sergeant Rex Colt action
figure og vet is that you tim i know you
come just like old days we kill
everybody hey everyone I'm agent bibs if
you really have a hard on for being
formal call me mr. Beebe's I don't so if
you call me mr. bids off the old pink
cap at you this version of robo dude is
equipped with over a hundred new Robo
accessories and Robo features including
voice action power punch and Robo dance
welcome dude will now demonstrate Robo
deaths Joan ice cream the same as he
raised his gun and fired it at the
rooftop but the black-clad mysterious
figure was too fast for him and vanished
in a flash of black cloth come out he
screamed oh the hell I you genetically
reborn in the sewers of New York named
after the great Renaissance masters and
trained as ninjas is
Avenged I will kill you or you are kill
me it makes no difference I love genre
why don't you talk to me you can't leave
me like this hello hands decider I asked
you not to call here anymore oh it's
unbearable isn't it suffering of
strangers the agony of friend I think I
may be a loss on a life the last one who
remembers what we did we tried to do for
the world I don't think this will be
kept safe for nearly long enough I might
as well try to anyone who finds this
know that I have done my duty a golden
triangle composed of three smaller
triangles united to form one came to be
known as the Triforce a relic of
omnipotent and omniscient power I shall
live and die at my post I am the sword
in the darkness I am The Watcher on the
walls I am the shield that guards the
realms of men dancing
fiery gypsies dance fire in our hearts
the higher the trees down
the faithful what's the forest for the
coming of the king their lanterns bright
they wait at night for the new world he
shall bring hello David welcome to your
xbox one gaming experience please say a
command of play halo 7 playing halo 7
thank you for your cooperation the game
started with familiar knee torino and
Gengar intro of the red and blue version
however the press Start screen had been
altered red was there but the Pokemon
didn't cycle through thank you please
continue down please continue as per our
agreement I want to be in this one
friend once who told me that the worst
mistake that you can make is to think
that you are alive when you're really
just asleep in life's waiting room